dear Hans we hope you're having a
wonderful time shoveling manure in the
Southern Isles you got what you deserved
you're 12 brothers made sure of that now
while some might refer to you as the
true villain of frozen we wouldn't give
you that much credit you tried to take
over Arundale in the sneakiest way
possible but you were no match for Anna
and Elsa's sisterly love
now Maleficent that's a villain you
could be a henchman at best unlike the
many Disney movies that came before it
the frozen franchise doesn't have any
real villains Disney totally flipped the
script on this one and that just might
be why fans can't get enough of frozen 1
& 2 keep watching to find out who the
real villains are or rather what they
are there were a few bad apples in the
first frozen film but we wouldn't go so
far as to name them the villains of the
franchise sure Hans tricked Anna into
falling in love with him and tried to
take over arendelle but there was a
greater evil at work Hans and the Duke
of weselton tried to weasel their way
into arendelle's good graces but their
attempts fell flat
unlike most Disney Princess movies
frozen didn't follow the usual template
sure Anna and Elsa lost their parents at
the beginning of the film and Anna did
meet a charming Prince but Elsa didn't
get rescued by a knight in shining armor
instead she was saved by a princess in
shining ice hands in the Duke of
weselton may have stirred the pot but it
was Elsa's fear that was to blame for
the series of unfortunate events that
take place in frozen after nearly
costing Anna her life when they were
just kids Elsa gave in to fear and it
swallowed her whole
she was so afraid of her powers that she
repressed them and it totally backfired
on her Elsa never learned to step into
her power or hone her craft she saw
herself as a monster and an outcast and
her fear grew to new heights after she
lost her parents Elsa's powers are
linked to her emotions which is why King
Agner taught her to conceal don't feel
so while Elsa managed to keep it
together during her coronation ceremony
she couldn't contain her rage when Anna
pushed her buttons in front of their
guests and then said
the secret Elsa had tried so hard to
keep was now public knowledge by the end
of frozen Elsa would realize that love
was the antidote of fear she realized
this when Anna chose to sacrifice
herself to save her
Anna's act of true love was enough to
thaw her frozen heart when Anna was
moments away from Kristoff she noticed
Hans creeping up on Elsa sword and hand
he was about to strike so Anna had to
act fast
she chose love instead of fear prompting
Elsa to do the same if it hadn't been
for Elsa's fear the true villain of the
story Anna and Elsa would have never
lived a sheltered life and Anna wouldn't
have fallen for honza's tricks nor would
she have accepted his proposal so it's
plain to see that fear was the culprit
not Hans but we're not letting him off
the hook that easily and neither are his
brothers did you know that frozen is
loosely based on Hans Christian
Andersen's fairy tale The Snow Queen
well in that version The Snow Queen
herself is the villain of the story
Disney chose to revamp the 19th century
fairy tale but during some parts of the
film Elsa could be seen as the villain
of her story too after all she did set
off an eternal winter lucky for the
people of arendelle
else that doesn't have a bad bone in her
body I woke the magical spirit at the
enchanted forest okay that's definitely
not what I thought you were gonna say
we've already established that the real
villain of frozen was fear itself but
what about frozen - at first glance you
might think that AG nars father was the
villain after all he's the one who
decided to betray the North ultras and
his actions angered the spirits of the
forest which led to the fog barrier
being put up but Elsa and Anna's
grandfather's role was so minor he
couldn't possibly be the big bat of
frozen - so instead of focusing on good
versus evil
Disney chose to focus on a completely
different storyline where as frozen was
all about overcoming fear its sequel was
all about embracing change and finding
where you belong frozen - taught us how
important it is to be true to who you
are for years Elsa knew that she wasn't
where she was met
- b-but she felt an obligation to the
throne so she stuck around despite all
the pain it caused her unlike her
grandfather Elsa didn't succumb to fear
she put everything on the line and
journeyed into the unknown to find
herself she didn't let the expectations
of other people hold her back from who
she was meant to be we love how Disney
is flipping the script on these typical
Disney Princess movies villains aren't
the main focus anymore instead Disney is
focusing on the emotional journeys of
their main characters from overcoming
fear to righting wrongs to figuring out
where they belong and as a result Disney
protagonists are more relatable than
ever here are the things we love
catching up with all things Disney and
Nickelodeon so hit that subscribe button
if you do - and don't forget to click
the bell while you're at it this way
you'll never miss another video if
you're tuning into this on your mobile
turn on notifications on your YouTube
settings and that's a wrap on why frozen
movies don't have any villains we hope
you enjoyed our video before you go tell
us who your top three Disney villains
are in the comments below thanks for
watching don't forget to give this video
a big thumbs up we'll catch you next
time on the things